think about the way we break up with
each other right i don't mean like
you go on one date you didn't like each
other and you just whatever that's fine
that was somebody for four months
something happens you meet somebody else
you decide you don't like them
whatever it is and so you just ghost
them yep drop that connection
just unfollow on all the social media
you just stop returning
replying to texts you stop stop
returning phone calls
you just pre it's as if you don't exist
and for the other person
it's panic as as if you've been killed
in a car accident
which is they don't know what's happened
to you they don't know where you are and
they don't know what's happened they
can't get
and then once they realize you're fine
because they can look on social media
and see you're fine
now the massive amounts of insecurity
what did i do was it me
oh it just it destroys someone's
self-worth
all because one person was too afraid to
have an uncomfortable difficult
conversation
scream shout yell i hate you you never
treated me right blah blah blah
good have closure you know but the fear
of confrontation to the point where you
would
literally destroy someone's innards that
will have lasting impact
on how they relate to people from now on
all because you're a little scared to
say i think we should break up and see
other people
or i met somebody else and i like them
more
that's that is that's a very difficult
conversation to have for anybody
that's not easy or fun but
one person's fear creates complete
destruction in another person's life
and somebody thinks that's fine and that
those are all skills learnable
practicable skills
that are unfortunately flowing by the
wayside